the Joe Rogan experience you have to
work yeah and well I'll tell you
something though not all of them in fact
probably not most of them but some of
the of the hardest-working people that
I've ever seen in my life have been in
the plan I'm serious work I mean working
hard you know to make a living and what
are their families
is there a universal factor like when
you talk about how they got involved in
it is is the neighborhood is it people
that they knew they are family well let
me give you an example of why people
join the plan they're different reasons
in some cases it's my grandfather was in
the Klan my daddy was in the Klan so I'm
in the Klan and my kids are gonna be in
the Klan it's a family tradition right
passed down and when you are dealing
with somebody with with that kind of
time that you know a generational thing
it makes it a little longer for them to
come out it was it's hard to break
family tradition right another reason
why people join you take a depressed
town like a coal mining town in West
Virginia or Scranton Pennsylvania some
like that for people who are not racist
they they're hard workers they did coal
all their lives
grandfather dug coal father dug coal now
your death toll did cold after high
school so all you know if I were to hand
one of those people a vacuum cleaner and
say vacuum this rug they wouldn't know
how to do it all they know is digging
coal and they're happy they are making
their paycheck they're feeding their
family paying their rent whatever you
know they're not concerned about
people's color they're happy but then
the company gets greedy and decides hey
you know what we can save money make a
lot more money if we lay off our
employees and hire some of these are
these are immigrants whether they're
legal or illegal because they'll work
for for less than half of what we're
paying our people right and so they lay
off these people and how are these
people who just came over to the country
looking for work
and and they pay the mr. nothing so now
these white people who had never racist
or out of a job the bank is going to
foreclose on their trailer or their
house or whatever they can't put food on
their table the Klan sees these things
and the Klan will come into a depressed
town like that and hold a rally I say
the blacks have the n-double-a-cp the
Jews have the ADL you know nobody stands
up for the white man but the Klan come
join us
we'll get your job back you know you
that was your job your jobs not gonna be
yours but you're gone and now some some
[ __ ] or some [ __ ] got your job you
know well why is that come join us so
these people as I said we're never
racist you know they began thinking well
you know they're right my job is still
there and I worked that job for 25 years
you know and I got laid off for no
reason and someone else is doing my job
so what do I have to lose
give me an application and they sign up
so they're like you know coerced into
this group they may be a little easier
to come out you know you're talking with
them then a third reason why people
would join if somebody relocates to a
town that is very Klan oriented a lot of
people who um currently live there and
stuff you know if you want to do
business in that town you got to
assimilate you know you join the local
Country Club the local Chamber of
Commerce and the local KKK you know
those are those different reasons why
people will uh will join and depending
again depend upon how strong the ties
are or why they join can determine the
alum their longevity or their or their
their hold on it
what is the one that took you the
longest to crack well I'll be honest
with you I never set out to convert
anybody and even though in the media it
will say black musicians in verse 200
Klansmen or X amount of Klan members I
didn't convert anybody I don't even
convert one of them I will say that I am
the impetus for over 200 leaving the
plan yeah I know that for a fact
and people have told me
I'm out of because of you with things
like that but I did not convert them
they converted themselves I gave them
reason to think about their direction in
life and they thought about it and
thought you know I need a better path
and this is the way to go because what
would happen would be this it's like no
you know when you when you believe in
something some people just believe in it
just because it's that person saying it
right like in a way we have a current
president where no matter what he says
some people are going to believe and
others are going to disbelieve all right
um and that and that can go for any
president really if you're a big fan no
matter what you do what you say you have
a base that's gonna believe you
so I would tell these people when I saw
fault with what they were saying in
their ideology I said well let me tell
you why I think this is incorrect and
I'd lay out the facts for them and then
they now they may not concede right then
and there but when they go home they
check it out and it rolls around in
their head and they began thinking you
know Darrell does have a point but he's
black but he's black but he does have a
point but he's black so even though they
know it's true they don't want to
believe it was I'm black so it's like
that cognitive dissonance thing going on
so they have a straight internal
struggle and they have to make up their
own mind do I continue living a lie or
do I turn my life around and live the
truth
[Applause]